if you please I am Dorothy there's any
film that's withstood the test of time
and deserves the IMAX treatment it's
Wizard of Oz this film is so unique the
legacy its history we're really proud to
have had an opportunity to be a part of
it I'd started working with Wizard of Oz
back about 22 years ago and it's been
great to see it in different
incantations Wizards the oldest film has
ever been converted to 3d and it's a
real testament to the craftsmen who
worked on it and the photography at the
time the three-strip Technicolor that it
can still hold its own technologically
the original film elements had to be
scanned so they were sharp and then the
dirt had to be cleaned out the scratches
all the imperfections that had built up
over the years from the handling of
these islands had to be taken out
digitally then prime focus did their 3d
work
so we dealing with a 3d conversion the
layering of the shot is definitely key
as far as putting these with proper 3d
space
we have a lot of layering that they did
when they originally shot in 1939 so for
us we would have to go through and
isolate all those different objects and
then in 3d when we'd layer them make
sure that things that were closer to the
camera actually a lot more volume and as
they fell away from the camera we're
actually a lot less that way to the I
had seen natural as if we were standing
on the set I got their files that they
had done the 3d work on and I did the
color correction in 3d looking at it on
a 3d projector being in such a large
screen and being in 3d is literally
gonna put you into Oz the 3d experience
did heighten it a bit and now you put
IMAX on top of that and it's quite
powerful there's no question that we
could not have created this IMAX version
without the tremendous efforts of
everybody at Warner Brothers and their
restoration groups a lot of image
science has gone into DMR technology a
render based process which is really a
fancy word for saying a lot of computers
are churning away in the background so
here we are in the IMAX DMR production
facility where every Hollywood feature
destined for IMAX presentations is
optimized in Hoenn shot by shot to bring
out all of the detail and reduce the
noise won't you take me with you why of
course I will we're always trying to
mine information that's intrinsic to
that negative and contained in the
negative Dorothy for the first time I
saw that she had freckles and the
Scarecrow's face is birla and I never
saw that texture on television and an
IMAX you feel it
we've also taking advantage of all the
unique attributes of audio that happen
in an IMAX Eden Warner Brothers did a
great job taking the original Wizard of
Oz soundtrack and bringing it into a
surround environment IMAX takes it one
step further we have an extended dynamic
range which means our loud is louder and
our quiet is quieter we have a frequency
response that goes down to almost 20
Hertz while most others stop at 40 and
that's the stuff you feel that's what
makes it tactile so when you hear an
IMAX movie
I feel in reality I'm not afraid of her
I'll see you reach the wizard given the
legacy of the film really retaining the
spirit of everything that went into
making this film 75 years ago was
critical to us
from the conversion process you need
IMAX mastering there has got to been
usually a thousand people involved it's
magical it's beautiful it's intimate
it's emotional audiences they're going
to rediscover a classic
you
[Music]